you
[Applause]
what if there was a way to build a
thermostat that allowed you to turn down
the temperature of the earth anytime you
want it now you would think if somebody
had a plausible idea about how to do
that everybody would be very excited
about it and be lots of research on how
to do it but in fact a lot of people do
understand how to do that but there's
not much support for research in this
area and I think part of it is because
there's some real misunderstandings
about it so I'm not going to try to
convince you today that this is a good
idea but I am gonna try to get your
curiosity going about it and throw up
some of the misunderstandings so the
basic idea of solar GOG Nehring is that
we can cool things down
just by reflecting a little bit more
sunlight back into space and ideas about
how to do this have been around
literally for decades clouds are a great
way to do that these low-lying clouds
everybody knows it's cooler under cloud
I like this cloud because it has exactly
the same water content as to transparent
air around it and it just shows that
even a little bit of a change in the
flow of the air can cause a cloud to
form we make artificial clouds all the
time
these are contrails which are artificial
water clouds that are made by the
passing of a jet engine and so we're
already changing the clouds in their
earth by AXA or if you like to believe
it by super-secret government conspiracy
but where we are already doing this
quite a lot this is a NASA picture of
shipping lines and so passing ships
actually cause clouds to form and this
is a big enough effect that it actually
helps reduce global warming already by
about a degree so we already are doing
solar engineering there's lots of ideas
about how to do this people
have looked at everything from building
giant parasols out into space to using
bubble waters in the ocean and some of
these are actually very plausible ideas
one that was published recently by David
Keith and Harvard is to take chalk and
and put dust up in the stratosphere
where it reflects off sunlight and
that's a really neat idea because chalk
is one of the most common minerals on
earth and it's very safe it's is so safe
we put it into baby food and basically
if you throw a chalk up into the
stratosphere it comes down in a couple
of years all by itself dissolved in
running water now before you start
worrying about all this chalk in your
rain water let me explain to you a
little little of it it actually takes
and that turns out to be very easy to
calculate this is a back-of-the-envelope
calculation I made but I assure you
people have done much more account
careful calculations and it comes out
with the same answer which is that it
you have to put chalk up at a rate of
about ten teragrams a year to under the
effects of of the co2 that we've already
done just in terms of temperature not
all the effects but the temperature so
well you know what what does that look
like I can't visualize ten terra grams
per year so I asked the Cambridge Fire
Department and Taylor mill salt to lend
me a hand and this is a hose pumping
water at ten teragrams a year that is
how much you would have to pump into the
stratosphere to cool the earth back down
to pre-industrial levels it's amazingly
little it's like one hose for the entire
earth now of course you wouldn't really
use a hose you'd fly it up in airplanes
or something like that but it's so
little if you like putting a him a
handful of chalk and every Olympic
swimming pool full of Ray
it's almost nothing so why don't people
like this idea why isn't paying more
seriously and there's some very good
reasons for that um a lot of people
really don't think we should be talking
about this at all and in fact I have
some very good friends in the audience
who I respect a lot who really don't
think I should be talking about this and
the reason is that they're concerned
that if people imagine that there's some
easy way out that we won't give up our
addiction to fossil fuels and I do worry
about that I think it's actually a
serious problem but there's also I think
a deeper problem which is nobody likes
the idea of messing with the entire
earth I certainly don't I love this
planet I really do
and I don't want to mess with it but
we're already changing our atmosphere
we're already messing with it and so I
think it it makes sense for us to look
for ways to have sort of mitigate that
in impact and that we need to do
research to do that we need to
understand the science behind that I'd
noticed that there's a theme that's kind
of developed it tab which is kind of
fear versus hope or creativity versus
caution and of course we need both of
those so there aren't any silver bullets
you know this is certainly not a silver
bullet but we need science to tell us
what our options are and that informs
both our creativity and our caution so I
am an optimist about our future selves
but are not an optimist because I think
our problems are small I'm an optimist
because I think our capacity to deal
with our problems is much greater than
we imagined
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]